تواجد الان في جباليا البلد بعد ارتكاب
الاحتلال مجزره هنا بعد تدميره لعدد من
المنازل وهي ماهوله بالسكان مما ادى لوقوع
عدد كبير من الشهداء والاصابات وما زال
ايضا بعض المفقودين هنا الدمار كبير جدا
في هذا المكان حي سكني بالكامل دمر في هذه
المنطقه بعد قصف الاحتلال لهذه المنازل
طبعا هنا المنازل متلاصقه ببعضها البعض في
هذه المنطقه في شارع غزه القديم في جبالي
البلد طبعا كما نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار الذي
طال هذه المنازل والمنازل المجاوره تحت
ركام هذه المنازل هناك مئات الشهداء
مازالوا تحت الركام لم تتمكن الطواقم
الطبيه او الدفاع المدني من الوصول اليهم
لا يتوفر اي امكانيات هنا في هذه المنطقه
من اجل انتشال الشهداء من تحت ركام هذا
المنزل الاهالي يحاولون الوصول لعدد كبير
من الاطفال لم يتمكنوا حتى هذه اللحظه
بسبب عدم توفر الامكانيات اللازمه للوصول
لهؤلاء الاطفال نشاهد هذه الصور المؤلمه
هنا بعد قصف الاحتلال لعدد من المنازل هنا
في جباليا
البلد حسبي الله انتشال طفل من تحت الركام
هنا في هذه المنطقه لف لف
هشري هذا يحيى
معنا الان الناجي الوحيد من هذه المجزره
بعدما فقد اكثر من 60 شخص من عائلته من
عائله علوان هنا في جباليا البلد ليحدثنا
عن ما حصل وعن هذه المجزره الذي ارتكبها
الاحتلال بحق عائلته هنا في البيت فل ما
ننقش في البيت سمعت صوت الضربه اللي انا
لقيت كل اهلي ودار عمي كلهم مستش شادين
كلهم اطفال كلهم رضع كلهم ابرياء فش فيهم
واحد له في التنظيمات كلهم رضع وابرياء
كلهم اطفال مثل الورد كلهم نساء مثل الورد
لس الشد صهيون المتجبر قام بقصف الاطفال
دون سابق انذار وهذا الاحتلال المجرم سوف
يندم هذه هذه مجزره هذه ناس امنين ناس
مبعدين وقاعدين عند الجماعه هذول عند
جماعتهم هذه الدار تحتوي تقريبا دتين
ثلاثه تحتوي على 100 نفر
على 100 نفر وما فوق وفيهم اصابات كثير لا
احضار ولا تنذ ولا انظار ولا اتصال ولا
شيء هذه هذه حكومه فاشله هذه حكومه تش ما
لقت اهداف ما لقت اهداف للمقاومه صارت دك
المواطنين الابرياء كل اللي ماتوا هان كل
اللي ماتوا كل اللي ماتوا هون اطفال كل
اللي ماتوا هون اطفال هذا حرام عليهم هذا
هذا الدول العربيه اللي بدها هيك وهذا
امريكا اللي بدها هيك ونتنياهو فاشل
وحكومته ساقطه
باذن الله باذن الله مهما ينزل علينا صدين
وصابرين ومتحدي ناس قاعدين حي بالكامل
جماعه بدهم ياكلوا جماعه بحطوا اكل قاعدين
بدهم يطعموا اطفالهم لانه ما في لا قوت
ولا اكل ولا شرب ولا خبز ولا شي في البلد
ودبروا الاولاده طول اليوم مي واكل وشرب
حي كامل نزلت اج الطيران نزل عليهم ثلاث
براميل مش صواريخ ثلاث براميل هد عليهم حي
كامل حي كامل واحنا بطلع الجماعه بارك
الله فيهم كل ه الجماعه هول طلعوا في شهدا
وبيجوا من تحت الركام ومش قادرين مش
قادرين يطيعوا اكثر من هيك اطلع ايش بسو
اطلع ايش بسوي تحت السكف اطلع الشهداء
اطلع الشهيد ايش هذا هذا هذا ضرب هذا ضرب
هذا ضرب على اسرائيل هذا ضرب على اسرائيل
صواريخ هذه بنت ضربت على اسرائيل صواريخ
الحكومه الفاشله حكومه الهش عندك 76 يوم
واحنا تحت الحصار وتحت الضرب تحت الضرب
هذا وبطلوا يفرقوا بين مدن وبين مقاوم
بارك الله ف المقاومه مقام بتصدم وتتحداه
من كل جحور ومن كل الاراض ومن كل المناطق
وهو بلاقيه شدف بلط على المست على
المواطنين بفكر انه يمحي اسم غزه لا احنا
راجعين وراجعين وراجعين لارض ال 48
وراجعين للقدس ابا من ابا وشاء من شاء هذا
تقريبا دار 300 متر فيها اربع مخازن كل
مخزن في كلبه مش اقل من 30 40 واحد مخليين
يعني في في معه من السجل المدني صاحب
الدار هذه له تسع بنات
متجوز بجز
باوت المتجوزات كلهم انطوا تحت المبنى ما
ظل عننا حاجه نخسرها بعد هيك ماظل وظل
يعطي يظل يبعث واحنا بنعطي وعننا شهداء
كفي نتنيا وحكومه نتنيا قديش
بده من وسط هذا الدمار الذي خلفته طائرات
الاحتلال بعد قصفها لحي سكني بالكامل هنا
في جباليا البلد مما ادى لوقوع عشرات
الشهداء ومازال هناك كثير من المفقودين
تحت الركام انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه